- [Narrator] Think of ballet:
Nutcracker maybe comes to mind
or Swan Lake
but, probably, not this.
(manic orchestral music)
In the 1920s in Germany,
the Bauhaus design revolution took off,
buildings like this were out,
Minimalism was in.
But beyond architecture,
many spheres of art
were touched by the Bauhaus
school, including ballet.
- Triadic ballet has been
created by Oskar Schlemmer,
Oskar Schlemmer wanted to find a form
for new way of dancing.
Bauhaus went down to the functionality,
that's why he also created costumes,
which would throw away useless decoration:
the tiaras, the tutus,
the golden costumes.
- [Narrator] The Avant-Garde
Ballet debuted in 1922,
and it was made into a film adaptation
by the Bavaria Atelier in 1970;
then, in 1977, it was recreated,
giving birth to the version,
which Ivan now directs.
- [Ivan] So the costumes
relate to geometric forms;
that's why it's called
Triadic, three forms:
it's a square; it's a
circle; it's a triangle.
There are three parts in the ballet:
it's the yellow part,
pink and black.
Yes, that's it.
The costumes, Schlemmer wanted
them to restrict the dancer
not to have the complete freedom.
Oskar Schlemmer spent lots of his money
investing into the costumes,
went so far that his
family, when needed money,
he said, "Sorry guys, I have
to work on the costumes,
"you'll have to eat a
little bit more modest."
- [Narrator] And it seems like
Schlemmer's labor of love paid off.
Even today the geometric costumes
combined with the robotic dance movements
gets the audience's attention.
- You could hear people
giggling in the darkness
because the movements,
(audience laughing)
it's very successful, because
our audience can't believe
that this is 100 years old,
because it looks like
it has been done today.
There you see the visionary
power of Oskar Schlemmer,
and the ideas of Bauhaus,
and that's what this ballet gives you.
(audience applauding)